- He grew up in the 1930s.
To some extent, he has this
kind of Manichean worldview
that sees the rise of fascism
and Nazism on one side,
Stalinism on the other side,
and kind of Rooseveltian
democracy as a kind of
a beacon in the middle.
So by the time you get to the '40s,
having worked in a recess,
seen penetration by people
like Maurice Halperin,
who he worked with, who most
certainly was a Soviet agent.
He recognizes that you have to find a way
for the non-communist left
and the non-fascist right,
to work together in a way
that excludes extremes.
I think it's one of the
reasons that there's been
a lot more interest in that
book, The Vital Center,
recently because there's a
sense in which it resonates
because it speaks so strongly
about the Democratic project.